I was in Roxbury at the during the
Democratic Party convention and I guess
it was 2004 and was one of the founders
of progressive democrats of america and
PDA and i know our beloved tim carpenter
his spirit is is with us today that was
an amazing first day first conference
first meeting and you still got it going
on here so thank you very much
fifty years ago which as you know dr.
Martin Luther King jr. delivered his
impassioned plea to the nation at
Riverside Church in New York which has
been referenced earlier but in his
extort speech beyond Vietnam a time to
break the silence dr. King made it very
clear that it was past time that the
United States end aggressive military
actions curtail irresponsible defense
spending and prioritize addressing
poverty and racism in this country as we
face the uncertainty of the trump
presidency dr. King's call to action
should be instructive as we developed a
comprehensive roadmap for resistance and
for nuclear disarmament if we are to
succeed in creating a fair more just and
safe world we must heed his call so your
conference theme reducing the threat of
nuclear war is timely and it really does
set forth a blueprint from our drum
major for justice
this blueprint will allow us to end the
militarization which now is happening of
u.s. foreign policy kertel irresponsible
defense spending which it is and build a
real global campaign to eliminate lookk
nuclear weapons once and for all once
and for all we have this this time as
hours to do that in his historic speech
at Riverside a dr. King said this is
another quote from that speech which is
really a phenomenal speech he said a
nation that continues year after year
to spend more money on military spending
than on programs of social uplift is
approaching spiritual death so you asked
me to talk about how steps towards
nuclear disarmament and Erica did a
guerre zarok I just want to commend
Erica because she's been phenomenal
she's done a great job with helping us
on Capitol Hill so thank you Erica
that she gave my speech good to see you
but let me just first take you back 15
years which sets the stage for perpetual
war and why the house is beginning to
take steps now towards the debate and
legislative agenda for nuclear
disarmament and why your work is so
important right now now more than 15
years ago Congress passed an open-ended
blank check for endless war and as you
know I was the lone member of Congress
to vote against that 2001 well I know
the bill that authorization was a blank
check for endless war and while it was
interpreted to punish the perpetrators
of the brutal and deadly attacks of
September 11th it really did set the
framework to allow endless war to rage
out of control without congressional
authority or any president coming back
to Congress now report from the
Congressional Research Service three
years ago which I asked for it's a
Declassified report it shows that this
authorization had been used by this was
three years ago more than 37 times in 14
countries to justify military action and
of course wiretapping of course in
determined determinate detention
Guantanamo you name it it's been used
for that it's been used of course since
then many many more times and sadly we
know that under President Trump our
perpetual state of war is even worse and
really should trouble us all in just the
last three months the AUMF this is what
Trump has done he has sent more than
1,000 United States troops to Syria to
fight Isis no connection to 9/11 at all
of course they've used that res
Ellucian to do that send 300 Marines to
Afghanistan to fight the Taliban and
their reports that more will be on the
way he used a mother of all bombs of
course you know the Moab our largest non
nuclear bomb on an Isis cave in
Afghanistan and it's propping up a proxy
war in Yemen by funding the salary these
are only a few of the military actions
has been used recently under the 2001
AUMF and these are just the Declassified
event so we should all be disturbed that
many of trumps war activities are not
even public a nation only exists in a
state of perpetual war when diplomacy is
really neglected and devalued we know
that it's possible to solve conflicts
without bloodshed and bombs so it's
incumbent upon each and every one of us
here to show this administration the
power of diplomacy which again dr. Moniz
and President Obama did right now we are
seeing that diplomacy is at the
backburner for this administration which
is really in stark contrast from
President Obama now while I respectfully
and publicly did disagree with President
Obama's intervention in Libya and drone
attacks the use of the AUMF for many
military and non-military actions I know
for a fact that he did make a shift in
our foreign and military policy from the
bush administration I know that for a
fact he spent eight years making the
world a safer place through diplomatic
initiative under his leadership we saw
what was possible when we put down bombs
picked up phones and faced diplomatic
challenges challenges excuse me together
when his administration considered using
force after the horrific chemical
attacks by Assad in Syria they work with
Russia to get rid of the majority of the
chemical weapons when Congress was
reluctant to use force at that time I
was the House of Representatives Rep to
the United Nations and I was at the
Security Council with secretary Kerry
when that resolution passed that both
tests the Security Council unanimously
of course we now know that President
Assad had not gotten rid of all of the
hidden chem
weapons unfortunately but because of
that President Trump launched an illegal
unauthorized military attack against
Syria and while we were all outraged and
still are about Assad's use of chemical
warfare this illegal strength it did not
make the United States any safer it did
not help the Syrian refugees nor did it
rid Syria of the remaining chemical
weapons I know you all remember in 2009
when President Obama laid out a very
bold and aggressive agenda to seek peace
and security by reducing the number of
nuclear weapons eight years of
diplomatic efforts followed the
president's pledge and after nearly a
decade of persistence the Obama
administration together with our allies
were able to negotiate a deal that put a
lid on Iran's nuclear program and
created the most expensive and intrusive
nuclear verification regime ever
negotiated I was pleased to be part of
working with the White House Secretary
Moniz on a very difficult joint
comprehensive plan of action and it was
really difficult to get this through but
musing and I remembered we had a day
public awareness red phone we called to
Iran I authored the legislation to end
our nation's counterproductive
no-contact policy so we've been doing a
lot on Capitol Hill prior to the joint
plan of action to build the public
support for that this deal has and will
continue to make the world a safer place
during the Obama presidency we were also
reminded that the power of diplomacy is
not just reserved for the executive
branch members of Congress are also
uniquely positioned to move us closer to
a fair and more just and safe society
when they embrace the power of diplomacy
but now we must make sure that it does
not unravel we have to be very vigilant
on this Iran nuclear deal we've made
history together all of us over the past
eight years but I think we can all agree
that this is at risk with this
administration from the constant saber
rattling
between President Trump and King Kim
Jong
to tense rhetoric being released from
the Trump administration we've been
reaching and we I think have reached a
widest watershed moment in history I'm a
member of the military and Veterans
Affairs subcommittee I recently was part
of a congressional delegation to visit
Japan and South Korea and let me tell
you a couple of weeks ago I was in the
region it reinforced my concerns about
the potential consequences of rising
tensions and militarization we went to
the DMZ and I saw how volatile the
region is and how close we are to a
nuclear war we visited Tokyo and Okinawa
and the memory and impact of Hiroshima
and Nagasaki are very real and on
everyone's heart in mind
sadly our allies in the Korean Peninsula
have come to live with the constant
threat of conflict and that should not
be the case
now after returning from the region it
became clearer than ever to me that we
are not alone in our fear of what this
president's temperament may cause our
international allies also believe that
the president is capable of tweeting us
into a nuclear war that is why we must
continue to put pressure on this
president to give comprar give Congress
a comprehensive strategy for deterring
North Korea that puts diplomacy and non
military strategies at the forefront we
must also prevent any president
especially president Trump from
launching nuclear weapons without a
declaration from Congress we have to
have this declaration you can't use the
2001 AUMF we must also make sure
Congress immediately demands that the
United States adopt a no nuclear first
policy to place a check on the executive
branch no first strike its are proud to
have led my colleagues in a letter to
President Obama at the end of his
presidency urging him to adopt his
common-sense policy this common-sense
policy and so also I'm
to co-sponsor HR I think you know this
bill 669 which would prohibit a first
you strike from the president
absent a declaration of war by Congress
we must pass this bill and Congress must
stop being and missing in action if you
ask me we have a press conference
Wednesday 500,000 petitions we received
in support of this bill 500,000 people
are waking up to the threat of nuclear
annihilation and beginning to lobby
Congress and yes this is a political
struggle mobilizing on campuses
registering people to vote holding
members of Congress accountable such as
Erika laid out electing public officials
who support this agenda and taking out
those who don't and so I would urge you
to look at what's in your packet
mobilizing on campuses in response to
Trump's nuclear threat because it really
sets forth the political agenda that we
all need to adopt and need to work on
this day forward so many of you were
part of the effort to bring in the
500,000 petitions and I really thank you
for that it was really remarkable it's
phenomenal and we're beating the drum
now because of you on Capitol Hill it's
not just legislative efforts though we
must also pressure this administration
to work with our international partners
to lead the world in reducing the role
and number of nuclear weapons globally
and so I'm pleased to be calling in the
letter with to trump which Erica
mentioned reaffirming these principles
to ensure that the United States leads
efforts to prevent the spread of nuclear
weapons and materials and to pursue a
more cost-effective approach to
sustaining and upgrading the US nuclear
arsenal this administration is not just
leading us down a pathway to nuclear -
the build-up of a nuclear arms race in
fact the president intends to
aggressively militarized u.s. foreign
policy
altogether look at his budget you saw
this it's outrageous defense increase
more than 52 billion I'm on the
Appropriations Committee will tell you
who
talk to to vote against this perhaps 52
billion above last year's level
his budget puts forth a 1.4 billion
increase for the National Nuclear
Security Administration that's the NNSA
to build more bombs yet it doesn't make
our planet any safer nor does it advance
in an essays goal of nuclear
non-proliferation his ill-advised budget
priorities come at the expense of
funding other vital programs such as
housing meals on wheels for low-income
seniors and education again dr. King in
1967 said in his Riverside spree speech
he called it like it was and like it is
this is a none American agenda and we
cannot let it persist just know there
are many of us fighting tooth and nail
to eliminate the use of nuclear weapons
once and for all and believe you me I'm
not alone the Congressional Progressive
Caucus is leading the way in Congress
you've got to look at our budget I
co-chaired the global peace and security
task force excuse me and it really does
lay out not only a roadmap for
resistance but it reigns in the ongoing
waste fraud and abuse at the Pentagon
and makes smart investments in our
modern defense strategy so our military
can respond to current threats and
nuclear non-proliferation and it
decommissions our nation's cold war-era
nuclear weapons infrastructure as
outlined by the smarter approach to
nuclear expenditures and so you know you
have many members of Congress on the
front lines working for this now I have
to just mention this I work many of you
know for great statesmen congressman Ron
Dellums
I was a member of saying freeze saying
freeze some of you remember saying
freeze right now we worked on nuclear
non-proliferation and disarmament I
marched in the streets wearing my button
and carrying a sign that said a nuclear
bomb is an equal opportunity destroyer
some of you may remember that I visited
the children at Chernobyl
during a visit to Cuba after the 1986
horrific nuclear power plant accident in
the former Soviet Union I've also had
the honor of visiting Hiroshima I went
to the memorial and met relatives and
descendants of the August 6 1945 United
States and the world's first-ever use of
an atomic bomb I saw firsthand the
generations of families who carried the
kernel consequences of a nuclear attack
that experience and others reaffirm my
belief that we could not rest until we
rid the world of nuclear weapons these
personal experiences have really
informed and inspired my life to fight
for nuclear disarmament wherever I am
and whatever I am doing but you know
what we all have to live up to dr.
King's challenge to fight these three
evils as Rep Connally mentioned the
evils of racism poverty and militarism I
tell you I'm hopeful for a future where
we see our wasted war dollars reinvested
in our struggle for housing and our
struggling communities for justice an
America where we feed our hungry
children rather than building nuclear
bombs in America where no school is
without books because the memory was
spent on the money excuse me was spent
on another missile program an America
that lives up to the highest ideals of
our founding documents befitting of the
true passions of great leaders like dr.
Martin Luther King Junior's so I hope
that you will take from this conference
motivation the motivation and the
information for this resistance but this
conference is also a time to retool for
the fight ahead it's a time to pause for
planning on the path toward ridding the
world of nuclear weapons and as we learn
our lessons from the past as a movement
for nuclear disarmament
we must include people of color and the
nuclear disarmament movement which has
historically been a white progressive
movement must fight for justice and
equality because black lives do matter
black lives do matter so let's not make
those historical mistakes in our
movement as I close I am reminded of dr.
King's charge to us that peace is not
just the absence of tension but it is
the presence of justice and so let's
move on and make this a peace and
justice movement thank you again
[Applause]
[Music]